is about as far removed from the amazon
as you can imagine
but the patchwork of south
gloucestershire is now the front line of
an
urgent attempt to contain a significant
new variant from brazil
surge testing has started in local towns
after two members of the same household
tested positive for the virus
which spreads more quickly and can cause
re-infections
another case has yet to be traced i'm a
bit concerned about it obviously
you just have to be careful about it
very worried yeah very worried indeed
the students just set everything back
again now and then
unfortunately do the right thing get
tested and hopefully we'll keep it at
bay
three other cases are in scotland and
are isolating
but the missing person in england
completed a home test or local authority
test on the 12th or 13th of february
but didn't put their contact details on
the paperwork labour blamed government
delays in bringing in hotel quarantines
denied by the prime minister we are
continuing to do
everything we can to stop variants
coming in at our borders that's why
we've got a tough regime
but were we not too slow with the the
hotel quarantine i don't think so we've
moved as fast as we could to get that
going the p1 variant has three changes
to its genetic code that make it such a
concern
it has the same n501y mutation as the
kent variant which seems to increase
infectiousness by between
30 and 70 percent it also has the e484k
mutation found in the south african
variant which is known to help the virus
evade some antibodies but it also has a
unique mutation
called k417t scientists haven't properly
studied
what that does to the virus we don't
know enough
to understand able to understand if this
mutation
is going to be of concern for vaccine
efficacy
as far as we know now from the vaccine
companies
that we have approved vaccines from
they're still working
against this variant the p1 variant
spread rapidly in manaus in brazil in
january
even though more than two-thirds of
people had been infected in the first
wave by the original covid virus
huge numbers were re-infected hospitals
ran out of oxygen
it raises questions about our own travel
abroad
is there any prospect of a foreign
holiday this summer when new variants
are
crossing our borders we are still in a
zone of great uncertainty
about what the virus will do next
on top of that many of the vaccination
programs
in europe which is a place where we
frequently go on holiday abroad
are running behind ours and clearly
whether we can go on holiday abroad to
places such as europe depends upon
what other countries will say and do
in terms of foreign tourism
there was more promising data showing
that both covid vaccines in the uk
are 80 percent effective at preventing
hospital admissions in those aged over
but while there is uncertainty over the
effectiveness of the jabs against the
brazilian variant
every attempt is being made to stop it
spreading and undoing the good work
of the vaccine rollout thomas more sky
news